you
there we go 85 was the magic number in
this guy TIG de so what will we have in
response to e4 I've been experimenting
quite a bit with many different openings
I've been expanding my knowledge of the
game I guess you'd say let's try the
Scotch opening don't normally play that
I think most of the times I would play
three lopes but let's get some variety
in there now Queen f6 is a move and I
think in response to it we can also have
Queen to f3 I'm gonna go forward with
that and it's not because I'm overly
excited about Queen trades although that
that usually is the case but I think
that this is a pretty good line alright
now I think I'd do well to just keep
this tension I've played this before
let's get my Bishop out I'm not sure
what I want to do with this guy
sometimes c3 maybe d2 the reason I want
to keep this tension is because this
night couldn't really move these doubled
pawns wouldn't be as bad as blacks
double isolated F pawns and now I could
challenge this bishop so let me do that
developing with tempo it's another way
to view it I wouldn't have anything else
but to recapture and Bishop back is
certainly alternative this is one that
I'm not so sure about I think I just
developed
or do I
yeah why not that's not an uncomfortable
pin if the bishop played back to b6 I
wouldn't take because of this recapture
and then there's play on the a file if
anything I would consider a4 a5 to put a
question to him maybe I should do that
right now actually that's C and put a
question to that what's he gonna do okay
so I don't have to worry about the
bishop challenging my bishop on this
diagonal you guys get throwing rook H to
g1 I don't see anything wrong with that
with that I don't think castles castles
Bishop h6 there would still be night
here at age five or night back here
those would actually be the only two
options I don't know if I would run
forward with it if castles Bishop h6
night h5 I don't see a way to deflect
this night away from the defense of g7 I
have to be careful with this structural
defect I certainly have to be careful
about black gaining control over the f4
square I think in an ideal situation I'd
like to have this pawn a bit further I
do have some worry however if I play
this right now f4 night here Bishop h6
night here pawn push the King goes in
the corner my bishop is stuck
he's kind of stuck I'm tempted to maybe
play Bishop e2 looks like I'm under
developing f4 night here Bishop gets on
this diagonal maybe maybe that's not so
bad
I was thinking Bishop e2 so that I could
do this without fear of a knight move
maybe there is something to that you
know I'm gonna give it a shot
and you know what maybe this is now a
bigger threat in some sense Bishop h6
would maybe if if Bishop h6 Knight h5
would maybe run into trouble with f4
ideas because the bishop would be
uncovered on the h5 square so we'll see
how black responds to that material
balanced structural defects and now
pressure on h2 now that I think is going
to run into some trouble because now
this comes with the serious threat of a
fork and also I'm getting ready to push
my opponent's pieces around I and I
think I do well to do that so let's grab
some space with wit gain of time Bishop
here night here on push pawn push this
has to be good oh I could do
back-to-back moves pawn push and then f6
exploiting this pin this is going to
come with tempo and it might be kind of
close to how this is just hanging the
night
if the night moved I had f6 and I was
gonna win a pond but I think there's
anything better than just taking the pun
my opponent will maybe get these two I
doubt there's anything better there's
nothing there's not going to be anything
better I guess I'm gonna be dropping
this do I really care about that I just
want to trade let me complete
development I guess I'm gonna have to
part with this pond I'd rather give up
one of my doubled pawns than a perfectly
healthy b2 pond so how do I simplify
let's just get the rooks off I don't
know I don't know why that night didn't
move away its offer trades get rid of
pieces and with I don't know about
running my King out towards the center
just yet but certainly as it gets more
simplified I will be approaching with my
king but not just yet this bishop is
fantastic on the e3 square stops a
second-rank invasions there's really no
hope along the e-file or d-file and I
think the last thing to do well maybe
let me let me just stop that stop to
work make sure my time maybe maybe it's
okay to bring my king closer to the
center now yeah let me sneak this in I
couldn't do this right away I'd be
dropping v2 I don't want to I don't want
to do that let's get out of the way let
me keep that rook right there and if
this rook eventually comes back over
here if we have a trade of rooks and
rook place to see it I'm gonna pile up
on the c7 pond let me get out of this
pin I'm anticipating that maybe that
maybe it would be these pawns who would
be more vulnerable than this group of
three let's grab him and Bishop here
Bishop here get the bishops off and get
a pair of rooks off this will be another
square I'll look into squares where two
or more of my pieces converge
what's wrong with this get some more
trades and then I could finally do what
let's take care I'm gonna babysit my
night just like this for a moment
sneak my king up and then my king will
have a shelter with my rook
in some cases you'll have 200 I was just
just gonna say some case you have to be
careful about giving up too many pawns
if you haven't if you just have a knight
sometimes that could be a bit of a
problem and this is this is not clean
technique no it's not it's not clean
technique at all um I don't like this at
all actually I could have taken that
let's do it now comes with check very
very poor technique very very poor
technique yeah this is ah you're gonna
get all my pawns
and you get all my pawnees save one of
them can I save one of them
you can save two of them it's not good I
have to go back to this game because
there's definitely a better way to
convert that advantage of being up a
minor piece good game let's go back and
before it even got to that point let's
see how to improve for either one of us
so scotch I'm not sure what this
variation is called I think the first
time I saw it was I've on took played it
as white against I don't even know I did
I just I'm pretty sure he played it and
anyhow I'm okay with this double pawn on
the F file so we're oh this is this is
one thing that I question the bishop
eventually ends up residing where right
here and not so great square I think
better would be to drop him back on b6
in like I was talking about with my idea
of throwing a question to the bishop
because I I don't want to take because
of a takes B and all there although
they're both doubled and isolated this
rook has play and you could still be
expanding with your B and C pawns so if
you drop back my idea was to play a4 a5
and put a question to the bishop I think
he does well to be it stay on this dog
and I think that might be a slight
improvement and well you certainly have
to be careful if your castling into the
line of fire here with hmm I was gonna
say queenside castle but I wonder if I
could maybe snip this pawn and get away
with that I'm not sure the concrete
lines if the if castling queenside is a
good idea but at the very least consider
queenside castling in positions where
there's a half-open or complete a
half-open file for you
or a completely opened D file because
you accomplish two things you get your
King safe and your rook functioning in
one shot that's something too I think
chew on you Castle and this is running
into trouble so there's got to be
something different it's tough to get
your pieces working yeah I have this
central point this Knight is kind of out
of play
he's he doesn't have he can't rely upon
h5 anymore
yeah I think um trading since I haven't
went one way I guess to look at I have a
space advantage I have a pawn presence
in this I think you'd do well to welcome
upon exchange looking again a bit more
generally another reason why to maybe
keep this Bishop not only on this
diagonal but to still be in a position
to simply trade get another pair of
minor pieces off and then you'll do a
little bit better with maneuvering you
won't run into trouble with getting
pushed around with my pawns this is the
I guess this is really the one thing
that I'm just kind of going back to the
decision where exactly to deploy the
dark square Bishop I don't think there's
any better than the e7 to g1 diagonal
from there was downhill after I got this
piece all these pawn advances are pretty
much coming with tempo and how could I
have done better well here's one thing
why did I let this pawn get all the way
down here I should have stopped him cold
yeah cuz getting to a four it freezes my
b2 pond I don't think I don't know why I
wouldn't have responded with a four I
guess I was too focused on getting my
King central so that's maybe a slight
way that I could be improving right
there
and you're already threatening I didn't
even see this I was blind to this
lateral movement of the rook the c5 move
freeing up this he threw in the check
yeah I missed that that was a slick
little move if you go here now I dropped
my rook back and everything remains
defendant I just overlooked that my the
heart of my pawn structure if he goes
they become quite weak yeah
rat race at that point okay
good game mr. mr. P for short oh my
opponent by the way is saying that they
found that I would place c3 in response
to their Bishop b4 move - and they want
to display my structure oh yeah I
understand that that's like a way to try
and break down my structure I wouldn't I
like to be able to have my Bishop on d3
as a secure point so that's why I never
really gave that a thought so that
that's a good point that he brought up
it was something I was thinking about
but I didn't express it until I just saw
your question though are your your
comment I should say okay let me close
out
you